hace algunos años en 2010 gracias a la
generosidad de llanes rojas pudimos
concretar algo que en ese momento
pensamos que no era posible que es un
cineclub y janet nos prestó una azotea
en un viejo edificio de centro de
acapulco en donde cada miércoles a las 8
de la noche
proyectamos una película y la selección
de películas tenían que ver con nuestras
motivaciones de vida con el amor con la
construcción de paz etcétera pero lo
importante es que cuando diseñamos este
espacio se nos ocurrió una mercadotecnia
bastante burda la verdad pero muy muy
efectiva
invitamos a la gente diciéndoles que en
la primera proyección iba a haber una
cerveza gratis para todos los que fueran
afortunadamente se llenó el espacio que
era esta azotea y pudimos empezar a
construir una comunidad una comunidad
cinematográfica
y aquí me viene a la mente la frase
santín san agustín decía que milagro no
es algo que atenta contra la naturaleza
sino contra nuestro entendimiento de la
naturaleza
y en una ocasión estábamos ahí reunidos
en una noche y pasó algo que pienso que
puede ser semejante un milagro y de
repente en la película en una escena
comienza a llover
curiosamente
comenzó a llover también sobre acapulco
en ese momento y el milagro fue que las
20 personas que estábamos ahí reunidas
no nos dispersamos sino que seguimos
juntos viendo esta película hasta el
final y muchas veces ocurría en este
espacio que el conversatorio que el
diálogo que sucedía después de la
película duraba incluso más que el
templo de que el tiempo de la proyección
y así en mi mente surgió una expresión
que yo quiero compartir con ustedes que
entiende al cine como una comunión
creadora muchas veces me ha tocado ver
como después de ver una película los
asistentes
salen como un exprese especie de
procesión silenciosa como rumiando la
película rumiando alguna escena algún
diálogo en su interior y pienso que esto
puede ser el origen de una conversión
que no sabemos hasta qué punto puede
llegar
la segunda historia que quiero
compartirles ustedes en este espacio en
la universidad loyola y también ha sido
una bendición para mí poder dar clases
en este lugar tan maravilloso
en este espacio en un salón de clases
pequeño éramos me tocaba compartir y
dialogar con jóvenes comunicadores que
tenían la clase de apreciación de cine
y en este lugar recuerdo bien en una
proyección de una película polaca con un
nombre bellísimo que es breve película
sobre el amor
en una película que para mí tiene un
significado profundo porque es la
relación que sucede entre dos personas
que descubren el amor entre ellas y
además se descubren enamorados unos del
otro uno del otro
y recuerdo voy muy bien voltear a ver en
aquellos momentos más significativos de
la película los rostros de estos jóvenes
comunicadores y ver como en algo de
henán algo en ellos se iluminaba
y esto también puede ser el origen de
una conversión de una conversión
espiritual de una conversión poética
porque porque estábamos ante un cine
un cine que surge de lo no programático
un cine espiritual un cine que creo yo
surge de la dimensión más profunda de lo
humano y en ese compartir de ese
director se generan estos rostros
iluminados en estos jóvenes
y en el mío también
la tercera historia es un poco más
personal sucede en varsovia en polonia
y es en un momento muy complejo de mi
vida había pasado por una gran decepción
y me sentía en ese momento especialmente
desolado
y recuerdo así como una especie de
autómata haber llegado a una sala de
cine en el centro de la ciudad
curiosamente sucedía que en ese momento
estaban las proyecciones del festival
internacional de cine de varsovia y
también por una coincidencia que no sé
cómo explicar entre esa sala de cine y
justo comenzaba la proyección de un
documental y era un documental sobre un
proyecto de construcción de la nueva
biblioteca de praga un proyecto que los
medios de comunicación comenzaron a
ridícula radicular izar diciéndole el
pulpo no así se llamaba le pusieron los
medios de comunicación es porque si
parecía pulpo y era sobre un gran
arquitecto de república checa jan cap
esquí
el documental era sobre este proceso de
construcción
y en ese lo que veíamos en ese
documental era como a medida que este
proyecto iba colapsando víctima de las
burocracias víctimas de los juegos
políticos víctima de todos reconocemos
también en nuestro país
a medida que sucedía veíamos como este
gran arquitecto iba muriendo
y lo único lo único el único asidero que
vemos dentro del documental es de las
personas que amaba
y el amor se convirtió en el único
asidero de este personal
y
recuerdo bien como esta película
iluminó mi tristeza y me dio un poco de
y recuperación del sentido por eso yo
muchas veces he dicho y lo digo con toda
certeza que a mí el cine me ha salvado
la vida
y creo yo que la gran pregunta que me
hacía a esta película es algo que está
muy presente en muchas realizaciones
la pregunta es
he amado
[Música]
la pregunta que muchas veces nos hace el
cine verdadero el cine de la poesía es
si en verdad en verdad hemos amado
[Música]
la siguiente historia ocurre en la
periferia de acapulco
gracias también al apoyo frontal de un
egresado de la loyola gabriel brito
logramos construir proyecciones del cine
comunitario
y lo que hacíamos era que durante el
crepúsculo íbamos a las colonias de la
periferia aquellas donde teníamos la
certeza que eran los lugares más
violentos de la ciudad y en esos
espacios en canchas semi destruidas de
basquetbol con tres o cuatro cosas un
proyector una pantalla un equipo de
audio y vídeo hacíamos las proyecciones
y la gente en especial los niños y los
ancianos y las señoras traían sillas de
su casa para compartir en ese momento y
ver juntos la película
y una de las películas que más pasábamos
y aquí agradezco también el apoyo
logístico de david ramírez y alan unda
una de las películas que siempre
proyectamos era the kid la famosa
película de 1921 de chaplin y era
maravilloso ver cómo los niños se reían
con estas escenas que proponía chaplin y
me hacía recordar una anécdota que citan
sus biógrafos sobre este grandísimo
cineasta decían que chaplin siempre que
firmaba algo mandaba a sus ayudantes a
presentar los rollos con de película
a barrios y que en esos lugares cuando
ellos regresaban cuando lógicamente
rezaban siempre les hacía la misma
pregunta y la pregunta es si se habían
reído los niños
y yo creo que desde el cielo del cine
chaplin veía como estos niños al ver the
kid también su rostro se iluminaba y
había un espacio que se convirtió en un
santuario un santuario que en ningún
momento en ese instante suprimió la
violencia que lo rodeaba
un santuario que no era ajeno a lo que
sería en las noches en las madrugadas
cuando jóvenes adultos
quizás orillados por la miseria quizás
guiado por otro tipo de violencias se
mataban unos a otros incluso en
situaciones que nos recuerdan al
holocausto de la segunda guerra mundial
pero yo estoy seguro que algunos de esos
niños iluminado por el gesto de esta
película donde un hombre acoge a un niño
desconocido seguro que algunos de estos
niños en su reflexión interna pudo
haberse estafado de esos mecanismos que
parecieran ser indomables y que nos
orillan a las violencias que hemos
experimentado en esta tierra y en
nuestro país y en otros lugares del
mundo
pues bien yo pienso que este tipo de
historias solo pueden surgir de un
concepto que elabora abbas kiarostami
en relación al cine de su país y es que
él decía que la propuesta era un cine
pobre por fuera pero rico por dentro un
cine que aspire verdad a la construcción
de diálogo un cine que dé voz a aquellos
que han perdido su voz un cine que les
permita recuperar su rostro un cine que
nos permita seguir viviendo en el amor y
en la esperanza gracias
[Música]